walk in to this video playing en by 2
which beta which from Sweden oops let's
see he's taking a sweet time to play the
riff dumb let's see how are the early g3
getting popular mmm for him interesting
hmm yeah probably i need to do that this
is a position type i need to be be
cautious with I don't know it so well
with before okay he's played a five this
is interesting i mostly know the idea to
play Knight a5 and still see 5 and this
is obviously not possible anymore
okay so he doesn't mind to exchange my
somewhat weak porn at least I thought
that this week can I do that queen bee
327 I shouldn't be too bad hmm now this
he played really quickly I wonder if I'm
on the road to to something bad here six
years can be weak so to g7 or three or
four maybe to reform my not sure the
habitus Agnes really passive I mean I
need to if I go to the seven I must be
sure that I managed to play the light on
c6 away and see five candidates gathered
get into this Quincy to I've got my
before and here my t3 is not really good
at them this should be four maybe be
sure before how this can be an idea
maybe if I can if I manage to take on d
2 and he must really capture with the
bishop then I have accomplished
something my night is I know I've Knight
c3 and I'm and I'm playing that he ran
right into the Frog check and now here
even get getting the gills is even
getting the porn
ya thought 27 here could be good
threatening discoveries or maybe queen
bee AIDS queen bee aids to be five this
kind of idea I always have the captcha
yeah this is a good one I think
intending queen bee five and i can still
take on a five if you should attack the
bishop like queen bee three or so i can
take take on a five or queen bee five
yeah Quinn b5 is even a good move after
that yeah here we go and now and now
yeah let's just take it
it does not it does not really have any
any particular play nigeria h5 maybe
come on I i return i return something
here okay he can take with I can yeah of
course Queen takes I take on a four i
was thinking Queen 94 as well but term
this is stupid of course so this was my
idea to now get this nicely coordinated
position I still have two pawns only one
I thought I have to know only one
yeah but it's it's a very nice
positioner who didn't take
yeah and I'm not sure maybe this first
yeah open up open it up his king should
be weaker than mine it takes on c5 I can
take on e3 first and then only on c5
download time
if he takes a couple of times on c5 sf4
hang this was my idea
okay mom you can try for some counter
play but his king is also really weak
Queen g4 twin g-form we take if i attack
III still queen g4s giving him counter
play
I don't want to really move the Queen
ban 30 seconds the only way to lose this
game is really on time here you just
have just blundered h-bomb I only have
20 seconds though so on so i hope i'm
not not not Blanche anger will game him
check time morning check check region
second check grid check check check
check like we've taken the Queen I could
have taken the Queen I don't believe it
check out what again check check check
check check
check check check check check game yeah
I captured it the last porn with 10 10
hundredths of a second yeah not blue not
winning us again heartbreaking I mean
what a game completely one-sided stuff
you never ever threatened anything let
them yeah I just 30 seconds for this for
this simple move I mean what am I doing
here root g 6 is of course no words and
well g5 was just trying to force matters
but it's probably not the best way chat
Lee check it should window it should
really win the queen ant game with good
play should be winning and he also the
first is check check that the channel so
blunder Jack we need one Chanti I can
just take the Queen and I saw it
immediately afterwards yeah you could
have my I could've taken my queen yeah
well ah what the game after after all
this plan during the exchange yeah it's
really strange sometimes the kind of the
kinds of ups and downs that you have at
the moment already playing like no words
yeah I don't really know what to do
about that just keep on playing and it
will get better that's my experience but
I can really don't know how to how to
yeah let's say speed up this process of
getting better alright thanks for
watching